JEFF DUSEK: My
name is Jeff Dusek.
I am a course two
Ph.D. candidate.
My involvement in the class is
I'm actually a mentor for two
of the student project teams.
So Sruthi is on one of the
teams-- team Beverly Ann.
I also worked with team Art.
And I took this course
last year and found it
to be an incredible experience.
I have an interest in
assistive technology
that stems from
a grandmother who
was in a wheelchair growing up.
And when I was
asked to be involved
in the course this
year, I was really
excited to be involved again
and in a mentor capacity
was really a great
privilege in my opinion.
SRUTHI NURAYANAN: My
name is Sruthi Nurayanan.
I'm course six
two, which is ECS.
And in this class
this year, I was
working with Beverly Ann
on a grip sensor that
would help her detect when
her grip was slipping when she
was picking up certain objects.
So I was interested in building
some sort of technology that
would actually go to
someone and help them.
I hadn't really done
that before in a class.
And this class was, I guess,
pretty well advertised.
And I was interested in sort of
going forth and just building
something, even if it
was just for one person.
And so that's why I
decided to take it.
In terms of how my
expectations for the class
actually correlated with
what the class was like,
I think that in
some circumstances
it really did end up
being what I expected.
I got to build something,
which is really exciting.
I learned a lot about
circuitry and fields
I'd never known
anything about before
but was really interested in.
And all of that
was really what I
wanted to get out of the class,
as well as the joy from being
able to make someone something
that they're going to use
and that will help them.
And so that made
me really happy.
What I didn't think I would
get out of this class--
but I was surprised
to-- was sort
of the able to interact with
people with disabilities
and understand how they
interact with the world
and how assistive technology
can really help someone,
even if it's just
in a very small way.
So I learned a lot about that.
And I'm glad I took
the class for it.
JEFF DUSEK: Yeah.
So as far as my
expectations for the course,
one thing I really realized
taking this last year
is that this class and design--
and iterative design in general
really force you to
learn skill sets that
might not be something
that you come in with.
So last year we worked on
kind of a robotic arm project.
I'm a mechanical engineer.
And so some of the
electronics and the coding
were not really in my
wheel house, if you will.
So this year I was kind of the
mech-E person of the staff.
So what I was hoping was to
be able to help teams that
needed a little bit more
mechanical design, who maybe
come from backgrounds in
electrical engineering
or computer science and stuff,
that might not have that skill
set.
And I think maybe
we pulled that off--
would say you have to hear
from the teams about that one.
SRUTHI NURAYANAN:
So when we have
to collaborate with
our client, a lot of it
was just figuring out what
would help her out the most.
Because she came and
told us immediately.
She was, like, I
have this disease.
And I have bad
grip because of it.
And so we had to spend a
long time thinking about, OK,
what does that mean?
What parts of her hand
does she grip with?
When does her grip slip?
Why does it slip?
What can we do to
prevent it from slipping?
What device could we
even possibly make?
And so a lot of
the time was just
spent with her talking with
her about her experiences
with her disease and sort of
figuring out very, very slowly
what would actually help her.
And then once we were
able to get to that point,
it sort of snowballed
from there.
We were, like, OK.
We actually know what
the problem is now.
So we can make this device.
And then it was just
build, build, build.
And then we got it
done and it worked.
So for other students
or engineers who
want to collaborate with
clients with disabilities,
I think that it's a really
valuable experience,
and you should
definitely go for it.
I learned a lot and was
able to help someone.
And I think that in itself
made me really happy.
But in terms of things
to keep in mind,
the client comes first.
And you have to always
remember that you
are solving their
problem, not what
you think their problem is.
And we had to spend
a really long time
actually getting to the
root of her problem, which
is why I think in the
end our product worked.
So definitely listen
to the client.
Try to get as much
critical feedback from them
as possible, even though
sometimes that's hard.
Because they're just happy
that you're there helping them,
even if you're not making
them the best thing that
you possibly could.
And so definitely
listen to your client
would be the advice
I would give.
So I think the group
work went really well.
We were able to split it pretty
nicely into different sections
of work.
In the beginning we were
all pretty much just
talking with Beverly Ann
a lot about her disease
and her problem.
But once we were able
to analyze the problem,
we were able to pick
up niches of the design
that we were able to
split up pretty evenly
and work on and then
combine in the end.
I think definitely figuring out
how to split the work evenly
is the hardest part.
But once we were able to do
that, it went really smoothly.
I would say for our team
in particular, none of us
had any circuitry
experience coming in.
And we were making
a device that was
going to stay on
her at all times,
and it definitely required
a lot of circuitry.
So the biggest problem
was just figuring out
what kind of technology we
even had available to use
and how we could use
that to our advantage,
learning about how
circuits worked,
even at like a very basic level.
All of that was just
so foreign to us.
And so that was definitely
the hardest part to get past.
JEFF DUSEK: Yeah,
so as a mentor I
might have a slightly
different perspective
on the teaching of the course.
And I think a few things
are really important.
I would say as far as design
and design for our client,
there's really two things.
I would say that
making sure that you
have a really good
contextual inquiry--
so really understand your client
and understand the problem.
I think that's one thing
that this course does
that's a little different
from most design courses.
You're designing
for a single person.
And so you really get to
interact with that person
and understand them and
understand their problem.
And it's really
important to do that.
And that's kind of the starting
point for everything you do.
And so you really need to
get that contextual inquiry.
And the second thing that I
learned taking the course,
but then also working
with the teams this year,
is just the value
of iterative design
and prototypes-- no
matter what fidelity they
are, so even paper things
or cardboard things.
Sruthi's team with
Beverly Ann-- they
worked with a grip project.
And so they used things
like putty to kind of map
where the hand grips in
particular and those sort
of things.
And I think that's really
valuable-- is making
use of even kind of
non-technical prototyping
but to really better
understand the design space.
SRUTHI NURAYANAN: For the
professors and educators
for this course who are going
to teach it in the future,
I think that the thing most
important for them to remember
is that I think the students
all have really good intentions
but don't necessarily
know how to act on them.
Like in our case, we
were just really lost
with some of the
electrical stuff
until we were able
to find resources
that were able to help us.
And so I think the one thing
they need to keep in mind
is that we definitely are very
lost in some of the things
we have to learn how to do.
And so obtaining as many
resources as possible
is very useful for
us down the road.
So for example, in
our case, we were
able to use the
Cypress Engineering
Lab, which has a lot of
resources for electrical device
development.
But we didn't know about
it until mid November.
So until then we were
sort of floundering.
And eventually we were
able to get into the lab
and get a lot of work done,
but knowing that earlier
would have been helpful.
And so just find and exploit
all the resources you can get,
because they all
pay off in the end.
Take this class.
I really, really enjoyed it.
It's something that I
haven't gotten out of a class
before, because this
actually went to someone.
It wasn't just something
that I built and then dropped
at the end of the class.
It is actually going
to help someone live
their life in a better way.
And that's just
incredibly rewarding.